paranormal
why is my earpod working but yours isn't
they don't want you to hear as long as
you're smart do you know that they don't
want you to hear people think it's funny
but dude something grabbed my ass like
I'm telling you
I'm telling you oh
no I had to do this Mark and Debbie if
you're here
this is your chance
I know this is really tough
it was a damn donkey yes ladies and
gentlemen we do investigate strip clubs
hey I'm Zach Bagans uh you probably
recognized me from a show called Ghost
Adventures and I'm gonna be looking back
on some of my worst scariest funniest
shocking all kinds of moments from Ghost
Adventures you guys ready I am
my God this doesn't feel right so you're
telling me that we captured River
Phoenix voice you can see me standing
absolutely still while this doll's hand
moves 15 years of Ghost Adventures it's
kind of like a celebration but then
again it's like a shocking kind of thing
to know and that I'm still mentally sane
and there's a lot of people out there
too that think I'm just like overly
dramatic or like you know I react too
much or I get possessed all the time but
they don't understand that I'm a very
sensitive person I'm very empathic you
know I just lost my father not too long
ago and he started visiting me in my
dreams and was telling me things like
told me to tell my stepmom that the
spare house key to the house is in the
toolbox I called her and told her that
she just started crying uncontrollably
she's like oh my God the key is in the
toolbox I was looking for it that was a
visitation so it's just you know people
see this as a TV show and everything
like this but this is my life I don't
know what you're gonna throw at me here
so this is gonna be this is gonna be
interesting
no
the island of the Dolls my nightmare my
forever nightmare no no no no no no no
no no
you want me to relive this thank you
thank you et thank you very much this
place was created as the nightmare for
Zach this play I came described you I
don't know what to expect okay so I had
the genius idea of taking one of the
most haunted dolls in the world
contacting the owner seeing what happens
when I take this haunted doll and put it
at the island of the dolls with all the
other haunted dolls to see if they start
fighting like a UFC match
so this we put Harold in this like Hut
and in this Hut there was a shrine for
the guy who died that like created this
island because of a little girl that
drowned and all these dolls started
washing up on shore he started hanging
them all over the place so his Shrine
doll is there there was this massive
spider as big as my head that would just
sit front and center on the chest of the
shrine doll that was his doll that was
with his spirit so I had the genius idea
to take Harold doll it was a very evil
doll put it next to the shrine doll to
see if anything would happen right not
knowing that that I'm responsible for
that so I'm gonna get I'm gonna get all
the wrath of this moment but it was
weird when we put Harold down at that
moment you watch on our thermal camera
all of a sudden heat started picking up
on the ground beneath Harold as if
Harold was boiling hot from this these
are all the little
that go into why is Zach so weird this
is why I'm so weird because I I do these
kinds of moments I collect all these
haunted items over here I do I'm
surrounded by this I'm absorbed in it
[Music]
clown Motel why you gotta be showing me
clowns thank you you're just uh reliving
all of my nightmares we went going from
dolls to clowns thank you the clown
Hotel I don't know why I have a I have a
severe fright of dolls and clowns and
now I collect them
so we're at the clown Motel there's a
mannequin of a clown sitting down do you
see its hand on its on its lap watch the
hand did you see that let's hear you
laugh
the hand from the mannequin went off of
his lap okay if gravity caused that or
whatever I don't care
the timing of this was just insane and I
tried to debunk it and I was standing
absolutely still when the hand went off
of the leg I'll tell you what if that
clown doll would have stood up I would
have liked Floyd Mayweather punched this
out of it
because I I literally thought there was
a real person in that thing and there
wasn't it moved its hand in that moment
and I was completely still
very emotional place the Washoe Club
Mark and Debbie if you're here
this is your chance
I know you love this place
I spent hours
in here
watching you guys
that's a tough equip I've seen that in a
while
this was a place that was that meant a
lot to us it still does we had a couple
very close friends of ours that was on
our show for
many different times
[__] Debbie and everybody in the
Paranormal Community knew who they were
made they introduced everybody to EVP
the use of recorders electronic voice
phenomena
they were on our show so many times and
Washoe Club was our kind of
our bond
oh I love Gettysburg you have such a big
place in my heart
I gotta get over my my fear of flying so
I could go oh my God no you did you are
not showing this clip man I this clip
people think it's funny but dude
something grabbed my ass like I'm
telling you I'm telling you people laugh
at this but I it was such a hard grab
people were laughing that was funny but
I was serious as a heart attack that was
like straddling a mannequin that
resembled I think the lady who died
there I know but it's all it's all a
funny moment right everybody thinks it's
a funny moment but I felt something grab
my ass like very hard like a whole cheek
and grabbed it and squeezed it and it
was this is one of the most memorable
moments of physical touch from a spirit
this is The Viper Room yes yes
now I'm pretty sure that she knew him
and we didn't know we were just playing
her this voice
wow what's wrong
I'm hearing River Phoenix and she just
freaked out started telling us that
that she's recognized this as River's
voice after that the next voice was like
I'm really confused and it was the same
exact voice she identified it as River
Phoenix so we go grab clips of River
Phoenix's voice we put them up on some
type of a graph that Jay wasley who's an
expert in audio it was an exact match it
was like comparing my thumbprint
to my thumbprint every line matched on
the graph
place is the
the mysterious place of all mysterious
places
the Winchester Mystery House we've been
there a few times this is a place that
we've gone back to because there's
something so mysterious with Sarah
Winchester and how she kept building
onto this and I just love it oh this is
the mirror this is the mirror so this
was one of our most iconic captures
visual captures that we've ever captured
and I'm pretty sure that we captured
this in regular vision
like you'll see this as a night vision
but I don't think we captured it in
night vision
yeah watch yeah see I took the camera
off night vision this is incredible
this was one of the most incredible
visual captures we've ever watched that
now watch when we slow that down
watch when we slow that down
that is a hand that is a clear hand do
you see that that is manifested on
camera and disappears and is going like
this look
it's literally going like that like
waving it looks like a Mickey Mouse hand
s do you see that it's got his it's
thumb up it's like either giving a thumb
up or it's literally waving on us and
this was in in regular vision and not
only that but it manifested and
disappeared
the trans Allegheny lunatic asylum
people don't know that I like literally
let out and hosted this and
reinvestigated this for seven hours
Non-Stop
live so we had these like contestants
that we invited we thought that would be
a really good idea to bring them on and
to kind of experience what we experience
so I'm going back to check on them at
this point you remember this is live
so like
anything and everything can happen so I
was whispering she was like I hear
whispering but it was it was us but but
wait a minute I think this is when we
captured this scream everybody watching
us turn your volume up because I'm
pretty sure this is the moment hang on a
second
what is that
there it is
did you hear that
it was a blood curdling scream
Yorktown Memorial Hospital in Texas oh
my gosh is this when uh
[Laughter]
it was a damn donkey
I'm looking for we're looking for the
owner and we see this huge dark mass in
the distance just coming towards me and
I didn't know what it was we arrived
there and we saw the whole room we
didn't expect a donkey be charging us
like a get the Churchill Downs this
thing was in full Sprint and his name
was Spirit that's right you know that
this is the best line right here
do it Zack do it don't ever lunge a
donkey's ass never lunge a donkey's ass
that became like a people started
getting that on t-shirts never lunge a
donkey's ass
yeah Black Swan in
I'm getting chills watching this again
her mother died in the house and so we
were trying to make contact with her
mother because she's seen her mother and
so we're using a Spirit Box device the
sb7
and we did three sessions and we had
nothing come through I mean no like no
radio interference
nothing not a single blip okay we did
three sessions
and I brought her in to be with us to
use her energy and I said do you want to
try and make contact with your mother
she says yes and um I go is there
anything that you guys you know know or
or would talk about things like this
this is before we started and she goes
yeah we had a code word so we started
doing a session I started trying to make
contact with her mother and all of a
sudden we get this
woman's voice come through and say
Bossier
I don't know what the hell that means
what is Bossier
she is just like
emotions wait a minute
oh my God
she just said Bossier but I'm like okay
is that a word in English language I've
never heard of before should I get a
dictionary and she goes no that's our
code word that's our secret code word
and then just like
like chills down my body
and she goes we were supposed to go to
Bossier City which I guess is a place
where they gamble on casinos or
something and that was their word
Museum of Madness this was actually at
the my haunted Museum so this is Lady
snake she's from England she was a kind
of a darker witch and we investigated
with her at Hellfire caves and the
ancient ram in and she would do rituals
for us when we were first starting the
evidence that we would collect while she
was doing these was like
we have to have her back I had the good
idea of having a darker witch and a
white witch who's Patty negri
come into an area where there's a
cauldron from Ed Gein that is cursed in
where he would literally drain the blood
of his victims inside
and Lady snake was doing a ritual in
there and I was like hey
this would be a great idea what if she's
doing a ritual in there and I bring her
polar opposite into the same room I
didn't want them to fight but as
somebody that likes to create situations
that will provide interesting Dynamics
into various experimentation situations
I thought this was a great idea and like
she wanted to whack her over the head
with a shovel and put her in the damn
cauldron like I was gonna have to step
in before that happened obviously and it
got real nasty
Albion Castle it felt like a heat a moth
but with barbs on like the back of it
and I that's what it the sensation is I
had like three layers of clothing on I
felt that go down inside my clothing and
I ripped my shirt off in the same moment
and there was you could see there's
marks in the middle of my back right
there do you see that
and the Mark is going through the
bloodied part of the dagger of my tattoo
there's a scratch there and I think
there was more down down uh down below
as well now it's one thing when you get
scratches but it's another thing when
you feel the moment of it happening it
scared the [__] out of me
foreign
the Palomino Club yes we do investigate
strip clubs
but we don't go there when they're
operating we go there when they're when
they shut down no
no I had to do this we captured a figure
literally dancing on stage I just had to
mimic what what was being seen I always
do that whenever I capture a figure
doing something I always have to show
the example of what it was doing
so yes you get Zach you know I did
pretty good you know if this if this I
might maybe take that up as another job
opportunity or something I'm pretty good
at that aren't I God look at me shaking
my booty
not bad
a lot of laughs but also a lot of
Horrors the uh comedy store where I was
roasted by Jeff Ross we've been trying
to investigate this for you oh geez Jeff
Ross I was terrified of this guy I mean
I've seen him roast all these
celebrities and like when you see him
roast these celebrities you're literally
like oh my God this is the most like
craziest guy in the world he went from
roasting me and laughs
to all of a sudden talking about Brody
Stevens's friend as soon as he said
Brodie Stevens name the whole lights to
the entire stage they went off and
started flickering
and so immediately we got up we spoke to
whoever was working there the manager
because it was closed we asked was
anybody in the booth did anybody
manipulate that nobody was even up there
where those are controlled and after
that moment Jeff went from roasting the
hell out of Zach making fun of his
sweatshirt and making fun of my white
mask and all this kind of stuff to all
of a sudden his face went white as a
ghost and was like wait a minute
are you guys doing that
probably one of the most iconic
locations we've ever investigated the
Cecil hotel now I'm in the elevator
right now
I am playing the elevator game which I
think originated in South Korea
it's kind of like this it's like a game
it's kind of like an urban game you know
like a Bloody Mary it's kind of like
that where you push a different sequence
of elevator buttons you go to Five you
go to two you let the door open blah
blah blah and it's supposed to when the
door opens on this particular floor
you're supposed to feel something enter
into with you they think of woman
and there was a moment like I'm not
reacting out of nothing everybody I felt
an ice cold
massive air with like this energy enter
into the elevator with me
and I was wondering Elisa lamb they
found her body in the water tank on the
roof they don't know how she died they
don't know how the hell she got in the
water tank
and how she was acting in the elevator
with those weird moments like get moving
away from somebody I was like Hey as an
investigator I'm willing to try anything
was she did she know about the elevator
game
was she playing it and did she you know
summons a spirit to do something to her
because a lot of the belief is that a
spirit was after her so I decided to
play the elevator game at the Cecil
hotel which is one of the most haunted
hotels in the world to see what would
happen and I felt something entered the
elevator in with me
a place that scarred me forever
um The Devil's Den you're picking the
good ones here
this is a location that scarred me
now we're talking to a former inmate
here
and we we went here because it's
abandoned at the moment and former
guards were telling us that inmates
would experience things entering into
their cells and making them go crazy
dark shadow figures and he was a former
inmate and we didn't really understand
or comprehend the impact at first I was
like you know is he crying because of
what he went through here it's not fun
being in jail it's traumatic but then
all of this went to the the bad spirits
the bad ghosts that would enter into his
into his cell
and then I realized that this was just a
regular GA episode I realized after this
we have to make this into a two-hour
special and what I experienced at this
place it made me question whether or not
I'll be honest it made me question
whether or not
that I wanted to continue investigating
and that's something that takes a lot
for something like that to affect me at
that level for me to even bring that as
a thought
the Stow house this is the Stow house
yes great episode coming up this is the
part where I get really excited as you
can see
because these devices are just audio
recorders
you hit a record button
it captures just regular audio so we're
two rooms away at this point
we've now hurried
in this family these spirits of this
family they don't like people in their
house and we were getting evidence that
they didn't like people in their house
but leave now hurry like these are
direct
demands by these human Spirits for us to
get out of their house and this
particular investigation we captured so
much compelling evidence both visually
and audibly this was a very iconic
investigation
that never ever gets old not after 15
years
I might be investigating with you know
with a cane
um in in hearing aids you know what I
mean but
I just I I just can't ever stop doing
this I just love it and I want to thank
my brothers Aaron Billy and Jay we've
been through everything together and in
a community to
um a lot of craziness in this community
and to be able to stick by and to have
these guys by my side and and I'm by
their side and we've been through
literal spiritual war together
um but I wouldn't want to do this with
anybody else and so I just wanted to
thank uh you guys for doing this for so
long with me as well and
you know we love doing it I love our
fans and yeah
we'll see how long we keep doing this
before we turn into what we're hunting
and when I turn into that there's some
people I'm gonna haunt the hell out of
you guys got me to tear up you got me to
laugh
um you got me to get very serious and
intense thank you for you know giving me
this opportunity I think it's an
important thing to do I've never done
this
so I hope you all enjoyed it continue
watching us
foreign
[Music]